GREG KUELGEN: Hello, my
name is Greg Kuelgen.
I'm an architect with the
Apigee team at Google Cloud.
I'm very excited
to be here today
with my friend and
colleague Debora Elkin, who
will join us a little
later on to give us
an amazing demo of some
of this functionality
that we talk about today.
So let's get into it.
I'm not going to read
this agenda slide,
but there's a key takeaway.
How you can use Anthos
and Apigee as a means
for deploying secure APIs
while allowing developers
to focus on delivering
business value.
Let's set this up
just a little bit.
At my company, there is
an App Innovation Day.
I built a killer app,
Jellybean Auto Count.
We all want to win jelly
bean guessing contests.
The app I built utilized some
sick machine learning models
to quickly and
accurately provide
a count of the jelly
beans in any jar
just by processing a photo.
Everyone agreed that
this app was amazing
and we needed to make it
available to all our employees.
I've got this great code,
but how should I deploy it?
I went to my
colleague Maria, as I
knew she was a wizard
on our ops team.
Maria said, I have
just the thing.
We've been doing
Kubernetes for a while now
and had learned that it
was difficult to manage
multiple clusters, particularly
across different regions.
There was a new technology
that the company was trying
called Anthos GKE.
It promised to simplify
management of Kubernetes,
creating a consistent
experience for developers
while doing so securely.
It sounded fantastic to me,
so we went ahead and deployed
my app to Kubernetes.
My app was pretty basic.
But outside of following
secure coding practices,
I didn't have to concern myself
with security, scaling, et
cetera.
People loved the app.
Usage was through the roof.
I used this as an opportunity
to recruit some team members.
We were getting lots
of enhancement requests
and began working
through the backlog.
Since our architecture was
based on microservices,
we saw a proliferation
of services.
We quickly realized
that we needed a way
to help us manage and secure
all of these services.
Back to Maria.
Maria had an answer again.
There is a reason I
keep going to her.
In this case, we can
use a service mesh
to help us secure the services,
understand the interactions,
and help us generally
manage the traffic.
The great news is that we
have a fully managed service
mesh offering already
available as part of Anthos
called Anthos Service Mesh.
This was, again, a great relief,
because we had enough backlog
to get through without worrying
about managing all of the TLS
and certificates and
access control and routing,
and just all of that junk.
As you can see, we simply
layered in Anthos Service Mesh
and kept going on our merry way.
With just a little help from us,
the operators on Maria's team
added all of the policies
into the Anthos Service Mesh
to secure the communication
between all of our services.
All of a sudden, other
teams in the enterprise
caught wind and wanted
access to these services
we were building.
Before now, it was
just a couple of us,
and we all worked
very closely together.
We wanted to let other
teams use our services,
but we didn't want to
take a bunch of our time
onboarding these teams.
Back to Maria.
I'm sure no one is
surprised to learn
that she had another solution.
This time, Apigee hybrid.
It runs on top of Anthos
GKE, and the runtime
can be co-located
with our services.
It provides a way for us to make
our documentation discoverable
and allow internal
teams to gain access
to our APIs via self-service.
No need to talk to
anyone on my team.
So as you can see,
we layered in Apigee
to help manage
these APIs that we
were exposing to other teams.
More success.
At this point, Teresa, one
of the execs took notice.
She saw the
popularity of this app
and knew we had to
make it available
to external developers.
Turns out we already
had all of the pieces
in place to make that happen.
We simply needed to add a
few more Apigee capabilities,
such as threat protection,
rate limiting, and OIDC.
We also needed to ensure that
we could handle the load.
We simply deployed
another cluster
of GKE and Apigee hybrid in GCP
to ensure that we could scale.
So that's all great.
But as I stated,
I'm just a developer
that wants to deliver
business value.
I don't know anything about
exposing APIs to third parties.
How can this be made as
simple as possible for me?
With that, I'm going to
turn things over to Debora
to walk us through
how we might be
able to enable someone like me.
DEBORA ELKIN: Thanks, Greg.
Let's explore this with a demo.
In the demo, we will
see how we can leverage
CI/CD pipelines to make it
very easy to expose services
through secure APIs.
It is standard practice
when working with services
to use CI/CD pipelines to
automatically build and deploy
whenever changes are committed.
This not only increases
developer productivity
and software quality,
but also makes
it easy to ensure best
practices are followed
when developing services.
In the demo, the CI/CD pipeline
is governed by Cloud Build.
When new code is checked
into a repository managed
by Cloud Source
Repositories, Cloud Build
triggers a new build.
This will generate a
new container image,
check it into Cloud
Container Registry,
and deploy this container
into a service cluster.
We can use a similar approach
for making it very easy
to build an API from a service.
When the service developer
tags the source code,
Cloud Builder will orchestrate
the generation of a new API
proxy and deploy it to
an Apigee hybrid runtime.
Cloud Builder will test the
API is successfully working
and check the newly generated
API configuration back
into Cloud Source Repository.
Even without having a deep
knowledge of API development,
a service developer
can easily generate
an API that incorporates
the best practices adopted
by their company.
Once the API is deployed,
clients can access this API.
All external access
is mediated by Apigee,
providing a secure layer
and eliminating the need
to expose the Service
Cluster externally.
The demo we are going
to see is from the point
of view of a service
developer, well
versed in software
development, but not
necessarily an expert
in API management.
Cloud Source Repository is
useful code source control.
Typically, the developer
will also use a local editor
on their workstation to
work on the source code,
check to their local
repository, and push the changes
to the remote repository.
Cloud Container Registry is
used to store all the container
images that are generated
during the development process.
The services are deployed to
an Anthos [? ASM ?] cluster.
In this case, it is a
development cluster.
Additionally, there's
another GKE cluster
in which an instance of
Apigee hybrid runtime
has been deployed.
Let's have a look in
Cloud Source Repository.
In mature teams, the
structure of the repository
is generated automatically
when the project is created,
and it [INAUDIBLE] templates
that encourage best practices
in software development.
It even enforces them sometimes.
A very common practice is to
have CI/CD pipelines-- that
is Continuous Integration,
Continued Development
pipelines-- that are triggered
when code is checked.
The pipeline triggers the
build of a new container image
and deployment of
this newly built image
into a service cluster.
Let's see this in action.
The developer will work on
their local visual editor.
They will make
changes to their code.
And once they are ready,
they will commit it
to their local repository.
They will then
push those changes
to the remote repository.
When the changes reach
the remote repository,
a new build is started.
This is managed by Cloud Build.
Let's have a look at what
happens during the build.
The first step builds
the new container image.
It then pushes it to
container registry.
After that, it is deployed
to the Anthos Cluster.
The last step verifies
that all the artifacts
have been deployed and that
they are successfully working.
Let's go back to Cloud
Source Repositories
and have a look in more
detail to the structure
of the repository.
We can see that there
is an API folder.
In there, there is
a readme file that
explains the steps
necessary to expose
this service as an Apigee API.
Namely, we need to provide a
couple of API configuration
data and also tag
the repository.
That's all the developer needs
to know in order to expose
the service as an API.
The developer decides
to go ahead and do this.
So once again, we switch
to the local editor
and edit the
configuration for the API.
We need to provide a proxy
base, [? but ?] this is where
the API will be reachable.
And we also need to
provide the back-end
it will be connected to, in our
case, our Hello World service.
Once again, the developer
commits their changes,
pushes the changes to the remote
repository, creates a new tag,
and finally pushes the
changes, including the new tag,
to the remote repository.
Once again, this
triggers another pipeline
that's managed by Cloud Build.
This pipeline, in
its first step,
generates an Apigee API
proxy based on a template.
It then deploys this API
into the Apigee environment
and also generates all
the associated artifacts
required for the API to run.
It also shows an API
key that is required
in order to test this API.
The next step tests that the API
has been successfully deployed.
It [? simply ?] invokes a
couple of very simple requests,
one without an API key, and
the other one with an API key.
The next few steps check the
code generated for the API back
into the source code repository.
It is worth mentioning that
the API that's generated
incorporates all
the best practices
that a centralized API
team deems as necessary.
For instance, verifying API
keys, checking for threats,
et cetera.
Typically, this
centralized API team
will be in charge of managing
the templates used and will
continually update them
with best practices
as their security
posture changes.
Let's now take a
look under the hood
and explore what the API does.
For that, we will switch to
the Apigee user interface.
When we look at the API
proxies that have been defined,
we can see that now we
have a new one related
to our Hello service.
When we look into the
details of the proxy,
we can see that it is connected
to our Hello service, which
is available on the Hello
endpoint in the Anthos cluster
ingress.
Let's have a look at
the policies implemented
by this proxy.
Remember that these have
all been auto generated.
So first, it will add a
correlation ID to the request
if one doesn't exist.
If one exists, it'll just
make sure to remember it
so that it can inject
it back in the response.
It'll then apply some
threat protection policies
to ensure that no attacks
are sent, in the headers,
for instance.
It will then verify that
an API key is provided
and that it is valid.
It will then enforce quota
limits on the number of calls,
and finally will apply JSON
threat protection policies
on the payload of the API.
Before the checks
pass successfully,
it will forward the request
to our Hello World Service.
On the way back, it will
inject a correlation ID
into the Hello World
Service [INAUDIBLE]
preserve the one that
was sent in the request.
Let's now see the API in action.
In order to do that, we will
start a very handy feature
that Apigee has that allows
you to trace every request that
comes into the API proxy.
For that, we'll use some
pre-prepared requests
that we have.
The first one sends a
request without an API key.
As expected, we get a 401
unauthorized response,
because there was no API
key included in the request.
Our second test doesn't
include an API key either,
but it does include
a malicious header.
Let's test it out.
As expected, we get an error,
because the API has detected
a threat in one of the headers.
Our next test, it's
a valid request.
It is a request that
does include an API key.
As expected, we get a
successful response.
And by the way, this
is the new version
of the service that was deployed
at the beginning of the demo.
It also includes
a correlation ID
that was automatically generated
because our request didn't
include one.
Our next test does include a
correlation ID in the request.
When we execute it, we
can see that the response
does include that
correlation ID played back.
Let's now send a
few more requests.
If we send them in
quick succession,
we will, at some point,
hit our quota limit.
And that's when the API
will return an error.
Let's see how Apigee handled
all of these requests.
The first one is the
one that returned a 401.
That's when we didn't
have an API key.
The verify API key policy
failed in this case
and stopped any
further processing.
The second case, it's when
the threat protections failed.
Again, [? all ?] for the
processing is stopped.
The next few requests are the
ones that were successful.
We can see that
all of the policies
were successfully executed
and then their request
was sent to the target server.
When their response
was received,
it was forwarded back to
the client invoking the API,
including the newly
generated correlation ID.
The last request,
it's the one that
failed because we had
exceeded our quota limit.
And, again, any further
processing was stopped.
In this demo, we have seen
modern software development
practices that are
commonly adopted
by the developer
community when building
services, such as CI/CD.
And we have also seen
how we can leverage
these practices to easily
solve the problem of exposing
these services to external
consumers in a secure way.
The service developer does not
need to be an API guru in order
to build APIs that incorporate
all of the required
best practices.
I hope you have
enjoyed the demo.
Thank you for watching it.
GREG KUELGEN: Thanks, Debora.
That all made good sense.
And I think it's something
even I could understand.
But I have a question.
When do you generally
see customers
set something like this up?
DEBORA ELKIN: Well,
generally customers
with larger enterprises
and mature programs
are the ones who have set
this up in order to enable
a truly federated model.
By that I mean a model in
which API creation is not
concentrated in a small
team of API experts,
but rather distributed all
along the developer community.
GREG KUELGEN: OK, got it.
But we all know the
security requirements
are going to evolve,
sometimes quite quickly.
How do teams manage the
security of their APIs
across these distributed areas?
DEBORA ELKIN: That's
when we generally
see a centralized team
that is responsible,
not just for the creation of
these automated templates,
but also of the shared
flows that they use.
With a shared flow, you can
build reusable units of logic
that are invoked by the APIs.
In mature organizations,
security measures
are normally implemented
using shared flows.
If the centralized
team sees the need
to update some of these
security measures,
they will update
the shared flow.
All APIs making use
of this shared flow
will automatically apply the
latest and greatest security
measures.
GREG KUELGEN: Yeah, I
think that's a good plan.
So with that, I think
it's time to wrap up.
Today we talked about how you
can use Anthos an Apigee hybrid
together to secure APIs.
With Debora's
demo, you could see
how easy it was for a developer
to expose an API using
best practices set up for them
by an API Center for Enablement
or similar team, allowing
the developer to concentrate
on delivering business value.
I want to thank you for
watching this session
and offer to continue
the conversation.
Both Debora and I have set up
some expert one-on-one sessions
over the next couple of weeks.
We will also be
answering your questions
in the question and answer
session for this session.